[Music]
on this Saturday night a state of
emergency and BC's interior declared a
no-go Zone temporary accommodation in
the areas I have listed are no longer
available for non-essential visits
plus confusion as people Flee for their
lives in the shushwa
while evacuees from West Kelowna fear
for the worst we will start counting the
number of houses when we stop fighting
the fires
and a brief reprieve in Yellowknife
that's the city getting covered in rain
a scattered residents hold their
Collective breath
global national with Farah Nasser
reporting tonight Colleen Christie good
evening thanks for joining us the
Wildfire crisis is escalating in two
different parts of the country tonight
in the Northwest Territories tens of
thousands have fled Yellowknife as fires
encroach on the territory's capital but
we begin in British Columbia where a
provincial state of emergency has been
declared as the most destructive
Wildfire season on record gets worse in
the shoe swap region people in several
communities are scrambling to leave as a
fire more than 100 square kilometers in
size advances burning out of control in
the Kelowna area the large McDougall
Creek Fire exploded in size encroaching
on residents living there that Inferno
has already destroyed countless homes
and triggered evacuation orders for tens
of thousands and with more fires
sparking in the region firefighters and
residents are bracing for the worst
I think it's uh it's become evident that
this event is going to leave a long
lasting scar on our community this
brutal folks for me and thousands of
others and where do you go
really no place to go
30 000 people in BC have been told to
leave their homes as 380 wildfires burn
across the province we begin with the
crisis unfolding in the Kelowna region
Richard zussman joins us now with more
on the situation there right now Richard
there are many people Colleen that just
don't have a place to go as you heard
some stayed here at the local hockey
arena last night and that is why the
province is putting in this
unprecedented measure they are Banning
people from coming to this region to
stay in hotels in order to ensure that
there are space available for those who
may have to evacuate on top of those who
have already had to evacuate there's 35
000 more on evacuation alert all of that
has people in this community very
concerned
mind of their own rapidly burning their
way up the Ridge near kelowna's Magic
Estates neighborhood
Crews scramble to protect what they can
the extent of the destruction still
unknown we will start counting the
number of houses when we stop fighting
the fires that are burning today
soon as we know we'll share the
information officials say so far there
has been no loss of human life and the
province is putting in an extreme
measure Banning non-essential hotel and
Campground stays in the Okanagan and
shushwap areas we have an urgent need
for more accommodation given the numbers
of people who are being evacuated and
who are under advisory the situation
changes very quickly given the dry
conditions the wind has been erratic
contributing to the challenge of
fighting these fires but on Saturday
some good news calmer winds and better
conditions to beat back the flames it's
a good firefighting day it's a day where
we can roll equipment and cruise and
have them feel confident in some of the
efforts that they're doing out there
well the weather is cooperating there
are concerns from the RCMP a few people
are not and that is impacting the
ability to fight fires there are drones
flying through the emergency area
they are affecting our firefighting
efforts if a drone is in the area you
will ground a helicopter we need that
air sprays
those who aren't following the rules
Colleen that's pretty minimal compared
to everything else we are experiencing
here in the area it's the kindness of
people we are seeing more of all day
today people have been pouring into this
Arena dropping off food and drinks
officials say it's even too much and
they're asking people to start donating
through sources like the food bank and
we've just felt the wind pick up in the
last little bit that's not great for the
fire fight but obviously they're going
to be watching very very closely as we
brace for the next few hours here as
people are on high alert around these
evacuations
Richard zusman and Kelowna thanks
Richard
to the crisis now unfolding in the shoe
swap area several communities are now
under evacuation order as danger
approaches from the Lower East Adams
Lake Fire
oh my God
thousands of residents are now trying to
leave in any way they can as the 100
square kilometer fire rapidly grows
that's on top of the 32 square kilometer
Bush Creek East fire which is already
threatening the region
Melissa Carpenter joins us now from the
shushwap Alyssa what can you tell us
about the evacuation efforts going on
yeah I'm in Sorrento and Sorrento is a
sort of one of the hubs right here
communities have been evacuated since
yesterday to the north south and west of
here this afternoon this went from an
evacuation alert to an order now
residents here say that things have been
a bit confusing they've been confused
about whether or not they had to leave
whether it was an order or not but the
one thing they all agree on is that the
community has really come together to
support one another
the town of Sorrento eerily quiet on
what would normally be a busy Saturday
businesses including this fuel station
have closed their doors even the post
office displaying a sign that says it's
closed due to evacuation alerts
a lot of the firefighters heading over
to Scotch Creek are coming out of here
and getting gas to
to get there but it's
it's still a big question mark we don't
know
what to expect or what's going to happen
now this was the scene as residents and
visitors lined the road trying to get
out meanwhile others along this Valley
went into active fire zones to help
those trapped by the flames and smoke we
had a bit of a local effort everybody
went over in boats and pulled people out
of there and search and rescues over
there's a lot of firefighters doing a
lot of good work there still Steve
ly owned restaurant and store his
parking lot has been serving as a
makeshift muster point for firefighters
search and rescue and Scotch Creek
residents now only available to be
evacuated by boat
the scotch Creek Fire Hall has burned as
Sharon Taves is a resident and small
business owner there we're just heading
out on the boat back to Scotch Creek go
and see what's going on over there put
out some spot fires if we can if we can
help and see where everyone yeah just
see what the future holds some weren't
taking any chances evacuee Rod kelenek
left his home Thursday night now staying
at a Vernon Hotel some of the pictures
that we saw on people's ring cameras and
stuff of the of the fire uh you know all
the firemen and and police you know
going from door to door evacuating
people meanwhile these two visitors from
the U.S have been forced to extend their
Canadian holidays they were scheduled to
fly out of Kelowna Airport closed to
commercial planes so fire Crews have a
place to land and fight fires there I'm
from Tulsa Oklahoma originally from
Canada and to the states about 27 years
ago and I have family here so uh just
here to do a little visiting the
situation throughout the shoe swap
region remains fluid while emergency
Personnel continue to work around the
clock to try and save as many homes and
buildings as possible
now not only the Evacuate the evacuation
situation that remains fluid but there
are also a number of road closures I
want to show you what we're looking at
here this is the TransCanada Westbound
from Sorrento headed to Chase and the
only Vehicles getting through right now
are any emergency vehicles anybody
fighting the fires everybody else is
being turned around that means anybody
trying to get to Vancouver for example
will add about an hour and a half or two
hours to their trip they say right now
this road needs to be clear just to let
those emergency Personnel through and to
try and get to some of those hot spots
and to get to anybody who may still be
trapped or who may need rescuing Alyssa
Carpenter in Sorrento BC thanks Alyssa
and these are just some of the many
fires that are ravaging parts of the
province right now among them are
numerous blazes near Linton burning two
years after the village was destroyed by
wildfires and the two biggest ones are
the Stein Mountain Fire to the Northwest
and the nearly 90 square kilometer
kookupi Creek Fire to the South
evacuation orders and alerts have been
issued for the village itself and for
the Litton First Nation further east
near the Alberta border evacuation
alerts have also been issued in
Invermere with three significant fires
in the surrounding area
Global News meteorologist Peter Quinlan
joins us now Peter what can we expect
from the weather in the coming days
Colleen much more favorable conditions
are rolling in over the next few days
the winds easing back still with that
Northerly component though pushing the
fires closer to Kelowna and West Kelowna
but we're not going to see this
crossover where the relative humidity
Falls cooler than the temperature like
we saw late in the week when that
happens we get explosive fire
development but we have concerns for
Monday when we could see some more
thunderstorms and the possibility of
some more lightning that may reignite
fires further spreading Crews thin over
the coming days but some much needed
moisture May accompany those storms 10
to 20 plus millimeters would help with
the fire fight but after that we get
back into the heat in the Okanagan upper
20's to low 30s and when we get the heat
coupled with a bit of a breeze Embers
like this can reignite these are seen
falling from the sky in Lake Country The
Embers are reported as hot spots on this
NASA satellite map and also the fire
spots are reported as hot spots so any
of these locations can reignite with
just a bit of a breeze and a bit of heat
and sometimes they can stay dormant so
we could be dealing with this potential
for quite some time there are evacuation
notices right up to the WR Bennett
bridge and if the fire spreads there
they might need to close down an
important Corridor between Kelowna and
West Kelowna strong winds late Saturday
in the Yellowknife area those switching
to southwesterly on Sunday but really
there is not many wind directions that
are favorable for the community of
Yellowknife because the region is
surrounded by fires thankfully much
needed moisture is on the way as we look
ahead to the forecast with those highs
into the low 20s at times by next
weekend we could finally see some
soaking rains Colleen that would be good
news Global News meteorologist Peter
Quinlan thank you
tonight officials in the Northwest
Territories are watching those winds
Peter mentioned very closely with 95
percent of the city now evacuated only
essential workers and those refusing to
leave Remain the city's residents are
now turning to Alberta for Refuge of
mass Exodus with no shortage of
challenges but there was some good news
delivered to evacuees today Global's
Jeff simple is near Enterprise in the
Northwest Territories with the latest
Jeff
Colleen the roads out of Yellowknife are
today very quiet and charred and in some
cases still smoldering and burning like
this spot you can see here behind me 95
percent of the population of Yellowknife
has now left that community and now they
nervously watch and wait to see what
comes next
Daryl Delaney was part of the final
Convoy leaving Yellowknife crossing the
border from the Northwest Territories
into Alberta is Bittersweet there was a
lot of anxiety I can tell you in the
town a lot of panic he runs
yellowknife's largest seniors home we
got one more bus trip left and recorded
this video of the last group of
residents preparing to board a Canadian
military plane to help keep them calm
and their spirits up three soldiers even
pulled out guitars awesome job
[Music]
I come in the military uh big time these
folks were Stellar I think without them
the logistics of evacuation of 20 20 000
people would not have happened the way
it did all week thousands fled the city
and some left in too much of a hurry the
roadway is littered with car wrecks by
Saturday the highways leaving
Yellowknife were empty the mayor says
nearly all of its twenty thousand
residents are out I was able to sleep a
bit last night just knowing that the
majority of residents and everybody who
wanted to get out got out
she says most Who Remain are essential
workers Global News spoke with an ER
physician who's staying to keep the
hospital running but officials say
around 1600 non-essential residents
remain and have apparently decided to
wait it out we don't want to be doing an
emergency evacuation later on when or if
the threat comes so
really stressing to folks please leave
right now overnight Yellowknife received
some desperately needed rain and by
Saturday afternoon the fire remained 15
kilometers outside the city on the
outskirts of the evacuation Zone
thousands of people and pets are
sleeping in cars RVs and Tents anxiously
waiting for news
a little bit more about what's going on
in Yellowknife and then we'll decide
whether we continue soap or whether we
stay here and wait it out and those
evacuees just received a bit of good
news officials now say the fires are no
longer expected to hit Yellowknife this
weekend that's thanks in part to a few
millimeters of rain but tomorrow is
expected to be warm windy and dry
Colleen Jeff Semple in Enterprise
Northwest Territories thank you Jeff
coming up where there's fire there's
smoke how wildfires are impacting many
people far beyond the fire zone Plus
I'm Jamie Dahl in Hay River a community
that's been evacuated for a week now we
check in to see how they're doing on the
front lines ahead on global national
as wildfires hold a fierce grip on
Canada's Western and Northern regions
all that smoke is beginning to make its
way across the country this time lapse
shows just how quickly the smoke moved
into the BC interior blanketing the
entire area as the McDougall Creek
Wildfire rapidly spread as winds shift
smoke from BC and the Northwest
Territories is expected to make its way
across the Prairies potentially heading
even further east Catherine Ludwig takes
a look at the health impacts of all that
smoke
Relentless and record-breaking Canada's
forest fire season started early with
fires in BC and Alberta back in April
and with over 14 million hectares burned
it hasn't let up it's hard to say if
there's actually was a peak in the
forest fire season more more so than
just a prolonged period of forest fires
smoke comes hand in hand with the fires
in Vancouver Thick Smoke is now wafting
in from fires in the interior with waves
of smoke spreading across the Western
provinces all the way to the east coast
the air quality has been quite tour for
many areas of western Canada the smoke
that's generated from these wildfires
being transported in the upper level
winds thousands of kilometers away from
their source region and affecting the
air quality poor air quality levels
throughout the summer has created
countless days of haze and high health
risks last few days have have been poor
in terms of air quality and it's going
to get worse over the next few days and
I've been seeing more patients coming
into the clinic complaining of shortness
of breath and cough as the climate
changes the intensity of this season is
only expected to get worse
have to prepare ourselves for this being
part of the normal from here on in
um
despite the fact that we're doing you
know some folks are doing the best we
can to alleviate climate change it is
inevitable and it is occurring
government officials recommend n95 masks
to filter out harmful particles in the
worst affected areas that a declining
planet with worse air and extreme
weather events is going to have
incredibly injurious effects on our
health care System
say Wildfire smoke can have dire effects
on people with existing health
conditions children and the elderly but
It ultimately affects everyone Catherine
Ludwig Global News
I had rare storms Southern California
braces for a Year's worth of rain in
just the next few days
Southern California is bracing for what
could be catastrophic and
life-threatening flooding as hurricane
Hillary tracks north from Mexico the
rare tropical storm is expected to begin
pummeling the region tonight but
officials say strong winds and heavy
rainfall will be most intense on Sunday
and Monday it's triggered California's
first ever tropical storm warning
extending from the state's Southern
border to just north of Los Angeles
it's been 84 years since one came ashore
so it's a Once in a Lifetime event that
we're going to be experiencing
residents are stocking up on supplies
and laying down sandbags in high risk
areas meteorologists are predicting
parts of the region could see more than
a Year's worth of rain in only a few
days
on the Hawaii island of Maui the
Wildfire death toll has risen to 114 but
there are still as many as a thousand
people still unaccounted for search and
rescue workers with cadaver dogs
continue to sift through the rubble for
remains about 60 percent of the historic
town of Lahaina has been searched so far
the Lahaina fire was one of four that
erupted on the island more than 10 days
ago destroying at least 2 200 structures
next those who've stayed behind to help
those on the front lines
the devastation from wildfires in the
Northwest Territories is becoming clear
the Hamlet of Enterprise is almost
completely burned down and residents of
Hay River have been displaced for an
entire week as the fire threatens their
Community communication lines are back
up after a difficult few days for those
fighting The Fire And as Jamie Dahl
reports some who stayed behind are doing
everything they can to bring people home
Daybreak in the Northwest Territories a
land black smoldering and raging with
Wildfire tens of thousands of its
residents are everywhere but home the
streets of Hay River are quiet and empty
one week now since a chaotic evacuation
lunch on the go but there is one
building in town still buzzing non-stop
I'm very honored very honored Brenda is
normally a cook on a cargo ship she and
other volunteers are now cooking for
about 200 front liners they're
sacrificing their lives for this town
this community these guys are tired
they're hungry they're frustrated you
know so if I can joke with them a bit
get a good meal out with with their team
here and fill up their bellies it makes
me feel good I feel like a one-arm
juggler we found the town's mayor also
cooking in this kitchen hopefully the
Army arrives they're supposed to come in
and help with the guys on the front line
so that we can Blackline this thing and
get people back into the community but
it could be a while yet the fire is
about seven kilometers from town and
it's already taken a grim toll wiping
out most of the homes in a nearby
community we had some rain for a couple
days we still have warmer weather coming
this fire is still close by there's
still a lot of risk and in the forecast
you know we're we're prepared for some
challenging days it's it's estimated 200
of hay River's 3 000 residents are still
here Santa McIntyre couldn't move her
brother who has a disability I'm
watching houses I'm doing patrols every
day I go at seven in the morning go feed
the dogs all the dogs in town this is
the second time this summer this
community has been evacuated due to
Wildfire and last year they were forced
out because of a devastating flood to
say they are exhausted would be an
understatement but they have little
choice but to roll with the punches and
wait for Better Days
JB doll Global News Hay River
and that's global national for this
Saturday night I'm Colleen Christie we
leave you tonight with the
heart-wrenching scenes of what's been
unfolding in BC and the Northwest
Territories these past few days and what
those who have fled are going through
scenes that are sadly becoming all too
common thanks for watching hope you'll
join us again tomorrow good night
foreign
[Music]